hey guys I'm Ryan Wright 9kt du Bois
we're gonna be reviewing the trailer
today for the water diviner
it's a Russell Crowe movie I think this
is the one he directed let's hope he
doesn't sing in this one but comedy ball
just swings this way and I just knock it
home run home run my boys
Henry never come
hello mr. together and I gotta
I should buried it out beside their
mother mother or father
you can poke around update I didn't say
come on my way to go away there's
nothing time because
you walk off your farm you turn up in
this place of operation football my sons
were killed on one day I can't either
maybe you could happen you know what the
chance of foreign tourism he's the only
father who came cooking
many songs they prepare and go to the
funeral today if you haven't thought
about their if this is your son he did
not die he was taken prisoner
so he's a much I don't know
oops a necessity where I come
so you can't stay
go home mr. Corman
with my job to steer my boys to mannerly
how much how obsessed about the contest
it's a lot I know yes
the water divider first of all
unnecessary voice at the end there but
that looks like a tearjerker for sure
yeah oh my god now that's the kind of
anything you do of parents will get me
like [ __ ] bawling oh yeah like when
his daughter was dead oh it looks like
it's a powerful story in a lot of ways
because there's so much or more and it's
not some simple hey dizzy plot like it
really is like about a guy looking for
peace you know yeah well and it's one of
the few dignities that are really
Universal in the world is being able to
bury your family of course and traveling
miles and you know asking for that you
know dignity to be able to do that so
it's amazingly universal and something
that I don't there hasn't been a movie I
mean no I'm never see a movie with this
specific type of story yeah I mean like
there's sure there are some similar
themes but like I've never seen a movie
where the subject of it is so specific
towards you know like finding that
closure of knowing for like okay if
you're if your child is dead or if you
know if you heard about it like where
are they they're buying like know where
their body is and yeah as well as like I
know he's looking for one of his sons
too and like who he believes is alive
and like that scary feeling of hope
that's a scary feeling because it's like
you have so much hope and belief but
what if you are wrong you know but
that's his life his life has become that
home he leaves everything to go to this
exactly yeah you know war zone and I
don't know I don't know where it was I
don't know what era this specifically is
or well more exactly dealing we would
have despite that that is like a
backdrop for it because the real story
of this especially when it comes to war
stories we always get the perspective of
usually the soldier or whoever the
military character is
now we're getting the perspective of
like a family member like losing and
he's he's lost basically that whole
generation oh of course
those are his children yeah yeah the
daughter the three sons and they said
that he was the only father who came
looking for ya the sights of their
children's bodies that's amazing
it sounds like he's going to accomplish
a lot in the end and hopefully like when
he does I'm gonna be in that theater
wanting ball like it's gonna be some
tears of like joy and proud and make me
want to be a good dad one day yeah I
like a good drama and I'd like an
entertaining drama like there are some
dramas that are just traumatic and
muscle Crowe he was subtle in this you
know he was earnest but he was subtle I
was interested very interested in
watching him in this oh he's always
authentic yeah like even when he kind of
doesn't even give a [ __ ] about the film
he's like he's still Russell Crowe doing
an okay job last movie I saw man was
Noah and I loved him and know us I'm
watching this I'm like yeah he has that
salty has an authenticity it's like this
could be another role because it's
always harder to get that nomination
again you know to reprove yourself for
the Oscars but this looks like it could
be like an Oscar contender if people
remember this film by the time Oscar
seasons around that's what I'm hoping
for
I mean it's winning all the Australian
awards so I'm just assuming that somehow
in American cinema this could make a
strong impact I hope so
we are intellectual as what we have
established forgets a bit I'll put my
glasses on guys so you know that how
smart I am whoa whoa sexy nerd over here
what just happened what just happened I
can take him off well where'd you go oh
my god I also really liked the woman the
Maine woman who seemed not his wife but
it seemed to be the woman in the other
country yeah I was talking about him and
his love for his children she seemed
really captivating well that's another
thing too about this movie it actually
looks like an interesting adventure
as well like there is an adventure
aspect to it because he's encountering
different people and carrying different
families going into different parts of
the world probably that he's never been
to before exactly so it is like fish out
of water in a way but in a more serious
sense you have a good drama because he
also got entertainment going on at the
same time there could be a drama that's
really heavy on drama but be
entertaining still in some way films
nothing like this book the pursue the
happiness comes to mind like that is so
heavy on drama yeah you're like paying
attention the whole time yeah and I feel
like this film will be really heavy on
the drama but with its adventure aspect
the waves them the pacing looks it
doesn't look like it's gonna be some
slow boring film yeah it looks like it's
gonna really keep going so yeah I'm
totally down to see this film yeah
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the reel rejects
Katie has a channel too
yeah features a lot of sketches and
stuff she's a funny next Pollan Bella
Ryan you are an awesome and beautiful
human being yes who occasionally says
the worst things a human could ever
possibly say [ __ ] [ __ ] but in the
nicest possible way
[ __ ] [ __ ] are pleasant just carry on
doing what you're doing and more comedy
skits sketches maybe and your success
will flourish and blossom this guy's
really sweet to me you're really sweet
to me all the best from all of us PS
[ __ ] the haters haters gonna hate
Mac's smiley face boom you are beautiful
max thank you oh I can't be you oh it
might be your pretty sexy holy [ __ ] dear
you were [ __ ] her how high to fall
Italian what the fan why are you on
YouTube looking at videos you should be
out in the world [ __ ] you could
totally be doing that like right now
stop don't send me any more messages
don't comment on the videos just step
outside and you'll get you'll get your
dick sucking it's that simple
he could yeah if if Katie was in the
same room with you right now I I would
get your number and her mouth would be
full
you know what I mean you know I mean
Katie you know what I mean your mouth
would be full kind introduction words
pleasantries my mouth would be full of
pleasantries Oh it'll be pleasant all
right
they would be perfect you're a [ __ ]
thing about Katie's in it